Simon is conflicted about the nurses
talking to the government
as a striking paramedic he believes
health workers should be United in their
fight for pay and working conditions it
makes us feel like second-class citizens
and the frustration and disappointment
and anger at the government's choice to
speak to the nurses
representatives and not to our unions
is really tangible now
the last time paramedics went out on
strike they stood shoulder to shoulder
with nurses on the picket line but in
the future they may not have asean
nurses alongside them
there are five unions representing
health workers in dispute with the
government but inside this building only
one of those unions is in talks with the
government the RCN now that's led to
some anger and what can only be
described as a sense of betrayal one of
those other unions Unison has said in a
very strongly worded statement that the
government can't afford to pick and mix
Solutions and that it risks making a bad
situation even worse the end that
frustration was echoed by the BMA whose
Junior doctors are set to announce the
dates for their strikes they've given
the health secretary until tomorrow to
meet I understand that he's a very busy
man and it's almost because like a
Schoolboy he's left all his homework
until the last minute he's got multiple
disputes now with multiple professions
and we've all come to the same moral
calculation
nurses
physiotherapists doctors we have to take
strike action
the talks for the RCN are expected to
continue until the end of this week and
are likely to focus on next year's pay
rise which is due in April
one option is to backdate it by several
months effectively giving nurses an
extra pay Boost for part of this year
this year nurses and other NHS staff
below the grade of doctor were given an
average pay rise of 4.75 percent
for next year the government has
proposed an increase of 3.5 percent for
all NHS staff
the devolved governments have made
increased payoffs to nursing staff in
Scotland the RCN has recommended its
members except a 6.5 pay rise and in
Wales nurses are being balloted on a new
pay deal that would increase last year's
backdated payoffer by three percent
[Music]
so while there is some optimism a
settlement can be reached with the RCN
other Healthcare unions are warning of a
broken NHS work one that is now divided
to ashes Josh is Sky News